Мій син військовослужбовець Камінський Ілля Антонович зараз перебуває в Україні на "спецоперації".
Із самого початку він знаходиться там.
Це звернення записала мати військовослужбовця-контрактника з Бурятії Оксана Плюсніна.
Вона розповіла, що її син спробував розірвати контракт та написав рапорт про звільнення.
Разом із ним це зробили ще кілька військовослужбовців.
Так само разом з ним дуже багато бійців написали відмову від бойових дій.
Раніше в них усіх вилучили документи, паспорти, військові квитки через те, що вони можуть потрапити в полон.
Швидше за все це була хитрість, щоб забрати їхні документи.
Ілля Камінський служить в 11-ій десантно-штурмовій бригаді, сформованій з військовослужбовців Бурятії.
Якщо зважати навіть лише на дані з відкритих джерел, бригада зазнала серйозних втрат.
А рапорти про звільнення, за інформацією правозахисників, спочатку написали понад сімдесят чоловік.
Приблизно 64 особи з цієї бригади загинули.
І 77 осіб, які написали відмову - це багато, це великий відсоток цієї бригади, бо хтось уже й у шпиталях лежить.
А ці хлопці, які вижили і під Києвом, і на сході, коли їх перекинули, невеликі жменьки хлопців, що залишилися,
вони вирішили, що долю випробовувати не варто, наступними будемо ми, і тому потрібно себе рятувати.
Жоден із рапортів, стверджують родичі російських військовослужбовців, так і не підписали.
Частина відмовників, зрештою, передумали і вирішили залишитися. З рештою провели виховні бесіди. А потім перейшли і до погроз.
Погрожують кримінальними справами передусім і тим, що їх відправлять на передову.
Це основні типи погроз. І, зокрема, їх розділили на групи по 8-10 осіб, і нібито відвозять у СІЗО міста Луганська.
Ілля потрапив до другої групи, і їм почали розповідати: от ви подивіться, що трапилося з першою партією, кого відвезли до СІЗО.
От їх навіть не довезли, а вони вже різко захотіли на передову.
Їм кажуть: бачите, вони вже всі хочуть на передову, от з вами буде так само. Всіляко на них тиснуть таким чином.
Це не єдиний випадок, коли російські контрактники масово відмовляються брати участь у бойових діях.
Повідомляється, що у червні рапорти подали близько ста п'ятдесяти військовослужбовців з Бурятії.
Їм вдалося повернутися додому. Нині ж, за даними правозахисників,
у російській армії йдуть на різні хитрощі, щоб ситуація не повторилася.
Намагаються домовитися, але з найупертішими вчиняють, як із злочинцями.
Їх закривають, ніби вони вчинили правопорушення, втовкмачують їм, що ви дійсно вчиняєте правопорушення,
залишати Україну - незаконно.
Хоча це не так, мобілізація не була оголошена, воєнного стану в країні немає,
контракт - це така ж робота, як і будь-яка інша, у нас рабства немає, ви можете з неї піти будь-коли.
Є нюанси, звичайно, але рапорт - це заява на звільнення фактично.
Де зараз російський військовослужбовець Ілля Камінський - невідомо.
Зі слів його родичів, зв'язку з ним немає. Слідом за матір'ю контрактника з Бурятії відеозвернення записала і його дружина.
Мій чоловік неодноразово писав рапорт на відпустку через народження дитини, але цей рапорт так і не був підписаний.
Будь ласка, допоможіть мого чоловіка повернути додому та батька дитині.
Цей випадок чи не єдиний, коли родичі вирішили розповісти про нього публічно, зазначають у фонді "Вільна Бурятія".
Як правило, близькі російських військових намагаються не спілкуватися з журналістами.
А розповідати про те, що з ними відбувалося, уникають навіть ті контрактники, які все ж таки змогли повернутися додому.
Його мати вчинила дуже сміливо - Оксана Плюсніна, яка оприлюднила відео.
Фактично прецедент створено, конкретна мати конкретного солдата записує відео, в якому перераховує,
чим їм там загрожують та куди везуть. Це дуже важливо.
І якщо таких звернень буде більше, то робота буде ефективнішою.
Повідомлення про масові відмови воювати надходять і з інших російських регіонів.
Видання The Moscow Times повідомляє, що близько трьохсот людей із Дагестану
склали зброю та написали заяви про розірвання контрактів.
Ніхто з них поки що так і не наважився публічно про це заявити.